[Music]
in early 2014 choreo studio invited
slovenian photographer mathias tan
church to undertake a 3d photography
project in north korea inspired in part
by the country's own fondness for 3d
photography to produce keepsake
postcards and public art accompanied by
Korea's cultural engagement producer
Viki Mohideen plus two North Korean
guides mr. Kang and mrs. Kim the team
were granted rare permission to
photograph people living and working in
different cities towns and rural
communities they covered over 800
kilometers in this groundbreaking
project traveling from showcase capital
Pyongyang to Kaesong in the south and as
far north as the little visited
industrial city of ham hyung introducing
the process of 3d photography to those
they encountered it's like a stage you
know everything there looks like like a
movie set or like like a theater set and
then when you put in this set also North
Korean person with their traditional in
this context called costume or their
typical clothes it just definitely looks
like a still from a movie and without 3d
glasses it looks just as a normal photo
but when you put a 3d glasses on you can
almost look around them you can discover
the image and deconstruct it a deeper
look into North Korean society so we
brought this forgotten technology we
brought it back to North Korea and made
a new material come on this worker he
looks spectacular so tall and proud and
beautiful such as a rough and hard 13 hi
man
[Music]
this noise is just overpowering you've
got the clanking and clanging and as
with all factories they have a little
unsafe van to clear evolutionary music
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and it keeps saying hope go more away go
more away and it was like come on guys
what can happen is just a furnace
[Music]
I think it's really striking I think
it's beautifully lit I just think it's a
beautiful image
[Music]
it's a combination of what I wanted and
what is real and what is staged I will
definitely remember this shot forever
[Music]
this was a gorgeous day this was a
beautiful moment for us we went to two
cooperative farms traveled very far to
get here three hours to one Sun and then
another two or three hours to hammer
home in a tiny little van it's quite a
stir in part of the country I want to
show to the West that no matter what
they hear about it it's a country with
normal people that live normal lives
there is no other way no other better
way to show it then it's true portraits
it was one of those few moments from a
tea Ashley was able to stop somebody
quite naturally who wasn't presented to
us as one of the few people that we
related to take the photograph of she
struck me so much as a lady that works
on a farm I just wants to go on with her
work she wasn't star stock or suspicious
or any of those things that you
associate with taking pictures in North
Korea she was just like well okay people
often talk about how North Koreans want
to show us a certain side of the country
and they're trying to display some sort
of false idea of the country it's
certainly true that they only show you
the very best that they have but you can
look at this photograph and see the very
best farm that they have they are
planting rice by hand and they are using
animals to transport things and to play
the fuel its banking work
the thing is in North Korea no matter if
it's staged or if it's not staged it's
real in that place at that time since I
want to have pretty unified look and
feel on the photo I decided that I'm
gonna keep using flesh and to achieve
that I need an assistant you can focus
on looking at the people in situation
and you know that the technical part
it's gonna work I was up to my knees in
the mud and can his leather black shoes
and long
long pants he was basically hanging from
the edge holding the lights you know s
closest was humanly possible for him
[Music]
amazing assistant because he completely
got it he understood which flesh to take
where to stand and then we you know we
start moving we had a chance for natural
discussion and jokes and engagement and
it didn't feel like we were part of this
orchestrated project in North Korea I
felt like we were urbanites on a farm
taking photographs of these people in
their animals and they thought we were
idiots and
[Music]
in order to really have school
children's palaces and their
extracurricular therefore
extracurricular activities and the kids
are for their after-school this is one
of the few retro ones that's like I
think one to a year ago
the music was actually amazing the first
song I just want another song kin
another song I get response
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
everything about this room is very DPRK
it's a perfect shot with this piano in
the back red plastic three flops
portraits of the leaders not to mention
the seriously there's that rare moment
of actual truth she's literally looking
at the camera and she's engaging with
the audience through the photograph I
don't think she was that happy or
comfortable and I think it shows I think
that's great something that we would
consider the easiest or the most common
was the hardest for me a logical step to
represent North Korea was also to shoot
someone with the bicycle
but when I mentioned this it was like
quite a big node or like no I mean this
doesn't look you know to developed Oh
what about that biker what about that
biker it was just no no no no it's like
having two artists that you're working
with in the one side you've got the
artists themselves and then on the other
side you've got this very specific
country that works with a very specific
kind of rules that won't be budged on
certain things can't just grab someone
and say let's take a picture and I spoke
to him about how he'd done it in in the
south of China and I was like there just
simply won't happen then we came to this
big fertilizer factory all the workers
kept bikes will people with the real
transport and especially in front of
this beautiful painted poster of course
I was happy because was another small
victory for me it's one of my favorite
places to go because the soldier guides
are sweet and they have a certain
confidence in swagger despite the fact
that I was officially on a trip as a
photographer it was quite a struggle why
this person we're also a little bit of
unease outside of that soldier can I
take
I usually had only 40 seconds for person
which is nothing especially when you
really try to do a great portrait which
means good location good light good pose
you know good look in the eyes or
expression of the people I had even less
time because they were really reluctant
to take photo but on the other side that
was really lucky because there was this
window in the place with the amazing
natural light this is exactly what you
would expect to see this is a soldier
he's looking very stern Kang comes up to
him and is saying look you can't move
and as soon as the photograph balls
don't move because he'll take more
pictures and he looks so nervous and so
giggly and then as soon as it's like
right we're taking a picture of his face
transforms I just placed him in front of
the window do a quick test and a couple
of seconds later he was already gone
this picture of the women in the
foodstuffs factory and pyeong song is
just beautiful Vicky told me oh that's
the first time I actually see them work
I guess usually did not have electricity
when there is no electricity they change
their clothes and they go out on the
field and they grow the corn and when
the corn is ready they harvested and
they use the corn to make these cookies
they had also some noodles and also some
strong liquor everything made out of the
corn or the wheat that they produce
themselves on the on the fields they
kept giving us tons of those biscuits
and then well Matty ash and Kang were
taking photos of people oak Seok and I
were in the background just like getting
out of the short just like chomping
biscuit anyway nice biscuits we went
into another room
take a picture of the guy with the cold
noodle machine and while we were in the
room the noodles came out with a gap in
the ceiling and they went back up again
again it was really photogenic place for
me good light interesting machines I
think this is very authentic this is
what a biscuit factory in DPRK is like
it was just a photo waiting to happen
[Music]
[Applause]
the Roman soldier let's stop
we decided to put ham hyung on the
itinerary because we really wanted to do
something different with this project
that hadn't been done before and when I
just Nick and I discussed it certain
people in the tour's Department and
we're like really you're going to have
home you're not gonna be able to take
any pictures there because you can't
even the tourists can't so how are you
gonna take a professional photographer
there it's even worse and so we were
like we need to try we need to try and
push the envelope and there's no point
as just going in and doing the same
projects we have to try and further
we're just entering the security the
world yeah we had to go to this game
everywhere we went when if we went to a
steel factory first you go to museum you
are interested in you go to two
different floors and you're like nodding
and smiling and asking questions but
inside of you're like just mm-hmm
let's go let's move let's you know skip
the museum let's go to the factory let's
shoot so sometimes I lost a bit of
temper I was like yeah let's go and he
was always compromised either to push
through Viki to go as fast as possible
or to try to explain your guides that I
really want people so that was also one
of the clash we had you were really not
interested in museums you just want to
shoot people which for them were so hard
to understand and disappointing I really
saw disappoint us in their eyes and for
me was like hell yeah I mean I really
don't want all the museum's
I just here for the people so just it
was always how to communicate this as
nice as possible which was really
difficult but hence the amazing team
Viki was outstanding it's really without
her yeah it was would not be possible in
such extent
and you squeeze it and you can make
really horrible things by the end of the
trip they were like yes we know Mateus
what you want so that's why we arranged
it out of the four floors of the museum
we're gonna see only two and they also
you know try to push and get us whatever
we want even if it was a bit uh nice for
them so it was same in this photo in the
university we went to Missy and we went
to everything and they were like I was
like so can we shoot one of the students
they're like no no look it's a beautiful
student can we shoot it you know like
okay you know let's sure that you know
and in the end we got this shot
the light was one of the best lights
possible 3d effect it's amazing
beautiful subject in oka environment but
the a beautiful light which you know
does all the magic it was for spending
them there an hour being a little bit
pain in the ass and he was so nervous as
I recall very very nervous the idea of
having his photograph taken we were
probably amongst the first foreigners
he'd ever made and he was and he just
looks so composed and fabulous and the
light is so beautiful this portholes
concrete buildings great architecture my
plan was definitely to get at least into
some of the house and get some photos of
sportsmen there and this was a lonely
difficult day because we went to the
maternity hospital before we came here
and I always find cheering those
hospitals really really uncomfortable
it was just a very difficult day and
that just just kept going through what
he thought was the absolute best
photographing and that's the thing about
photographers is that sometimes it can
be the uncomfortable thing about them
and something awful thing about them is
that they warned the best photograph
[Applause]
since there was a big statue in front of
the hall with a guy flying through the
air with extended hands and legs I was
like well let's see if you can do this I
had to use the flash because it was
really dark and I saw there it casts
interesting shadow perfect that's less
so with a couple of adjustments and
angles we took advantage of the shadow
to make it photo even more interesting
[Music]
he wouldn't stop until he had absolutely
the perfect photograph okay you can
check and if he's happy then we finish
otherwise he repeats I show photo to him
was like look it's good but I think you
could you know do to be better if you
show this the professor is he gonna say
good jump or bedroom I'm serious not to
China has she not ah - sorry she's alone
and then he went he ran and he jumped in
he did this perfect
[Music]
[Music]
you